you are my girlfriend well maybe they
are boyfriend and girlfriend because
things seem to be heating up between
Ariana Grande and her boyfriend
collaborator Mikey foster after her
Lollapalooza performance in Chicago on
Sunday a source tells ET that ariana
threw a surprise birthday bash for one
of her bodyguards and Mikey was in
attendance adding fuel to the fire the
source revealed quote they sat next to
each other during the dinner our source
says the party went down at Top Chef
alum Fabio Viviani 'he's Italian
restaurant siena tavern where the group
gathered in a private dining room that
was decked out in birthday swag
requested by re herself quote she asked
for the room to include happy birthday
balloons and other decorations as well
as a special birthday cake created by
the restaurant but the love fest didn't
stop there
according to the source re and her
rumored new beau returned to the
restaurant on Monday and were even
spotted holding hands
[Music]
the source noted that the two arrived
and left separately and that the singers
mom Joan and a few other friends join
them for dinner romance rumors first
circulated after Mikey as well as scooty
Anderson of social house collaborated on
boyfriend with Ari
the trio dropped the song and music
video last week
yep that's Ariana and Mikey engaging in
some serious tonsil hockey Ariana Mikey
and scooty performed the hit during day
four of Lollapalooza and on Monday the
26 year old posted this selfie with her
and Mikey on insta captioning it with a
simple heart emoji the former
Nickelodeon star also posted a video of
him holding her dog writing why does he
love you this much it's weird
[Music]